all right welcome to this video let's go
before I guess random Oracle okay it's
going for column I didn't have that on
the board for no time I hope I remember
my my lines there it's been a while
since I studied it
[Music]
I think I played but surely - I never
got the mean lines on the board Indus or
whatever failed is the main line with
castles
Bishop e7 rook t1 this was my main line
in the book and keep it simple for
you know it's interesting it leads to a
very complex position okay so he allows
me to put this outside of the chain
[Music]
not sure if I want to play a four or not
cringes 396
I probably have to regroup this anyway
you
in the long run I should go for
form
interesting it seems that he wants to
put it onto d6
I cringe III was stupid that was a
stupid move because after Bishop g5
there is well again it's not the end of
the world but there's night before and
there is something that mmm I should
have
taken into account
okay let's go back then
okay I can actually take here right
three
Oh f5
like when development is bad yeah
f5 could be a problem
they did not want to
to play see for him
f-five it should just be played
no doubt
in my it must be right I mean if I take
it there c6 is hanging but black should
open this now if I get just like one
more move then I'm definitely okay
hmm okay
green movements if he takes my position
is very okay
yes Sakura Gakuin age six or something
my development just sucks completely
and the only thing I can do is night a
three to get it out
I'm surprised that he has a decision
here
yes to move the Queen training makes no
sense then I get 92 and f5 is prevented
that I can grind on forever
not sure
really
you
interesting
okay I'm going to do it just just
because I'm I must develop the night
yeah I cannot I cannot keep it like that
forever
okay he wants to go f5 I do understand
but now it's not so clear wait wait wait
wait
I have night
three
yeah I mean I don't have to worry about
this I can still after f5 player three
or something
ultimately I'm going to play c3
and put pressure on the pants that is
coming
like had to go f5 to make to make the
temple college and he was just a lot
better developed
and I think that was a it was a
necessary necessary action
you
right so if a five a five and then
before I am no not before
I see four
and in 94 this night be seven
okay anyway he went down I know I'm
taking the pawn
okay um whoops c7
[Music]
and this is probably better you keep
everything keep the pants black cannot
really activate all that well
it's not possible
Najee six then probably have to play
before
hmm Wow I didn't see that
so much soon
knowing
a lost some time I mean I think it's
probably winning but certainly and not
something that you would resign him okay
the engine says you can but it was very
interesting really
I miss plate like from here I miss plate
this a little bit I think the the the
the order of moves in particular was
imprecise I am I want to play rook f1 to
play a four but the move order was just
bad the computer suggests to play a for
first and is probably right now I didn't
like that and now from here I think you
can can look for improvements how the
engine likes my play heads funny
Knight a3 hmm that makes it awful lot of
sense and then to finally get an F for I
also have Bishop h6 sometimes
so night and so Bishop d5 was real how I
am and night before was a good reply as
expected
Bishop d5 was a bad move I played all so
far too quickly
yeah after this I'm okay
so he went to ship here instead of night
before I am and this is not good hmm I
have to play 93 as I play it but this is
just not looking like a good position
that is odd this is weak that soccer he
played the bishop moves
this this gives some advantage away
should g5
now I went for went for this I should
play Queen g3 that's a detail of battle
and I can play clue e 2 instead of B 3
yeah it's funny that the engine still
likes my position but anyway I'm totally
convinced f5 is right and it's the
engines top move the only Mook that
gives equality so f5 I have to check and
then I wasn't sure it was just like my
assessment was based on
just on general considerations night f5
it seems to be good for white according
to the comput
I'm surprised I thought you should have
some
immediate activity one problem is said
this doesn't work out that it's just it
doesn't add up
everything is hanging
and here at Quincy forum that is an
important month
and this if I managed to get this into
the play my structure is excellent but
black has activity
so I think you should do that Quincy
form and now [ __ ] age six has to be
played
clean clean move Quinn away somewhere
age six and I'm here this I think is a
little bit better due to the structure
g6 group c1 immediately and then c3m
okay maybe you don't need this move it's
rather bit over prophylactic but I don't
think time matches much
and she'll probably make sure tank this
is just already no fun
I would be 6555 yeah and him that is
basically winning
ninety-four
[Music]
but I mean what I did I think is fine he
has really no real way to improve this
position by much
Oh Luke c7 i blundered dad
oh that is that would have been super
annoying now my Lucas trapped
Oh God good at the end
hey good that this didn't happen and I
have to do this and just hope that
somehow they it's totally lost I cannot
do this yeah you can we cannot
and maybe maybe maybe you could draw
this but well that was not good yeah
after you were look at it it's it's it's
winning again like at the end you know
he lost some time but it was a winning
position okay they were interesting
thanks for watching